votre votre mari dit de vous on ne la
force jamais à dire ce qu'elle ne veut
pas dire et pas davantage à faire ce
qu'elle ne veut pas faire alors moi je
vais quand même vous demander quelque
chose pour conclure je ne vous ai je
vous ai toujours connu avec un chignon
c'est vrai qu'une femme a cheveux longs
et toujours différent d'une femme à
chignon si je vous demande de défaire
votre chignon est-ce que vous le faire
alors je vous le demande voilà tout de
suite si vous voulez vous avez je n'ai
pas toujours eu les cheveux longs et je
regrette beaucoup d'avoir les cheveux
longs j'ai les cheveux longs depuis que
je suis ministre enfin j'ai commencé à
laisser pousser à ce moment-là parce que
c'était beaucoup beaucoup plus facile de
se recoiffer quand on est en voyage tout
le temps et que il faut être
pratiquement présentable c'est la
première fois que je fais long alors je
me souviens une fois comme ça aux
États-Unis où j'étais d'ailleurs en
déplacement officiel et j'ai voulu aller
me faire faire un chignon chez le
coiffeur pour être coiffé pendant le
voyage et merci beaucoup je vous en prie
et je n'ai pas pu trouver le coiffeur
qui sache faire les chignons bon ben
j'avais qu'une chose à faire c'était
c'était accepté d'avoir les cheveux
longs